- I mean, coming from Europe
as an Irishman living
in London many years,
Eurovision Song Contest
was a big event on TV
and remains so.
So it's all the European countries
and they show their greatest
and finest singing acts
and they're quite
outrageous, some of them,
they really go for it,
and it's very humorous
but it's very sincere
and it's very real
and it's very important
to all the countries
and it's taken to heart
and practically, you know,
all the countries of Europe,
they all close down when
the show comes on TV.
And, of course, you know Abba
is one of their finest acts
that, you know, lit up the world.
And I remember when they won
and so Abba seems to have
played a part in my life
having done two movies-
- I know, I was gonna say, I
saw "Mamma Mia", I loved it.
I loved every actor in it,
it's literally like they were like,
"So what actors do you wanna see
in a film together that you love?"
And then "Mamma Mia" enters.
It's literally, all
you guys, I love Meryl,
I love the whole cast.
Was that a really cool thing?
Like, did you always sing,
was that, like, did you sing
in front of audiences before?
- No, I mean I sang when
I was at drama school.
You had to sing, you had to do everything
when you're a student
but no, I made a film,
one of my little films
with my company, Irish
Dreamtime, I did sing in that,
it's a movie called "Evelyn"
which is a beautiful film,
but I sang Irish pub songs.
It's a lot different than singing in Abba
and singing, you know, a
warhorse song like "S.O.S.".
So it was mildly terrifying
(Kelly laughing)
and they didn't employ me
for my singing talents.
It was, you know, it was rough and ready
but I think it was played with such heart
and such sincerity, the whole film.
- [Kelly] I loved it.